[Music]
you've probably heard by now how
cryptocurrencies have been having quite
the success
in 2021. bitcoin topped 58 000
in february of this year ether the
world's second biggest cryptocurrency
also hit record highs even dogecoin
which was invented purely as a joke
surged more than 50 percent after tesla
ceo
elon musk tweeted about it today it's
easier than ever to get a piece of the
action yourself
you can buy a fraction of one bitcoin
using an app like coinbase but that's
not the only way you can get your hands
on some crypto cash
of course even that method will come at
a price welcome back to our channel
today we're going to look at the actual
costs associated with mining
cryptocurrency
if you haven't already make sure you hit
that subscribe button and ring the bell
so you never miss an upload from us
bitcoin is a great way to send and
receive money but it's not exactly
created for free
your number one expense is likely to be
on power the community of computer-based
miners that create
cryptocurrency uses an incredible amount
of electrical power
and this process has also led experts to
believe that mining cryptocurrency
is far from environmentally friendly not
only is the process
painstaking and costly but it's also
rewarding on occasion which means you
won't get lucky every time
still mining has a magnetic appeal for
investors
interested in cryptocurrency because
miners are rewarded for their work with
crypto tokens but before you run to
spend money on equipment you have to see
if mining is really for you
the primary draw of getting into mining
is of course
being rewarded with bitcoin you don't
have to be a miner to own tokens
you can always buy cryptocurrency using
flat currency
and trading it on exchange sites like
bitstamp you can also earn tokens by
shopping or publishing on platforms that
pay in cryptocurrency but if you're
still interested in becoming a miner
keep in mind it won't be easy you've
probably heard that miners have to solve
complicated math puzzles in order to get
tokens but that's not exactly true
what they're actually doing is trying to
be the first miner to come up with a
64-digit hexadecimal number
called a hash that is less than or equal
to the target hash
it's basically guesswork but the job
being guesswork doesn't make it easier
the total number of possible guesses for
each of these problems
is in trillions and it's incredibly
painstaking work to be the first to
solve a problem
you will need a lot of computing power
to mine successfully you need to have a
high hash rate which is measured in
terms of mega hashes per second
gigahashes per second and tara hashes
per second
that's a lot of hashes when bitcoin was
first founded
people were able to compete for blocks
with regular laptops and computers at
home but that simply won't cut it
anymore
the difficulty of mining bitcoin has
changed over time
there are 1 million mining rigs
competing to solve the hash problem and
they'll likely reach a solution faster
than a setup where 10 mining rigs are
working on the same problem
bitcoin is designed to evaluate and
adjust the difficulty of mining every
2016 blocks
or roughly every two weeks when there is
more computing power working together to
mine for bitcoin
the difficulty level of mining increases
to keep block protection at a stable
rate
less computing power means the
difficulty level decreases
to give you an idea of just how much
computing power is needed when bitcoin
first
launched in 2009 the difficulty level
was one
as of 2019 it is over 13 trillion
meaning if you want to mine
competitively you will need to invest in
powerful computer equipment such as a
high-end
gpu or more realistically an
application-specific integrated circuit
that'll run up a cost of anywhere from
five hundred dollars
to tens of thousands of dollars that's
not even including the power required to
mine
cryptocurrency the more bitcoin that's
mined the more complex the algorithms
get
and now that over 18.5 million bitcoin
have been mined the average computer can
no longer handle those demands
so now mining requires special computer
equipment that can handle the most
intense processing power needed to get
bitcoin today
and of course these special computers
need a lot of electricity to run
since the epic come-up of cryptocurrency
the energy used to mine it has continued
to rise
climbing to the equivalent of the annual
carbon footprint of argentina
written testimony presented to the u.s
senate on energy and natural resources
in 2018
claimed that bitcoin mining alone
accounted for one percent of the world's
energy consumption
in fact bitcoin mining energy
consumption is set to exceed
private consumption the global energy
use of all bitcoin mining will
eventually reach the power uptake of
bangladesh
which has a population of 160 million
people
in early 2020 researchers predicted that
the cost to mine bitcoin will be at
around 12
000 to 15 000 after the block reward
halved in may 2020
but it's now cheaper to mine bitcoin
than those earlier estimates well
not by a lot but enough to make a
difference to people who have been
mining for a while
lately miners have been flocking to
iceland a country known for its moderate
climate and abundance of hydropower
bitcoin has also become more affordable
to mine in recent weeks due to two main
factors
difficulty adjustments and cheaper
electricity in sichuan china
electricity in the region costs 0.04
dollars per kilowatt hour thanks to the
rainy season
and abundance of hydropower plants in
the area which has made the break-even
cost to mine bitcoin in the range of 5
000 to 8 500 even individual miners
running commercial mining equipment like
the antminer s9
are operating at a break even cost of 8
206 dollars
but do the benefits outweigh the cost
how much will you earn
given the current situation the cost to
mine one bitcoin
is eighty two hundred and six dollars
and sixty four cents and the value of
the coin
is fifty six thousand two hundred
dollars meaning
it's still profitable the cost to mine
bitcoin for both big mining pools and
individual miners can range between five
thousand and eighty five hundred dollars
so miners have more incentive to sell
the cover operational costs
instead of holding on to the bitcoin
they mine the rewards for mining reduced
by half
every four years when bitcoin was first
mined in 2009
one block earned you 50 bitcoins or btc
in 2012 this number came down to 25 btc
by
2016 it came down to 12.5 and in may
2020 it dropped to 6.25
in november of 2020 the price of bitcoin
was about 17
900 per bitcoin which meant you'd earn
111 875
000 for completing a block though the
value may have dropped it's still a
pretty good incentive to solve the hash
problem
this splitting in half or halving a
bitcoin is necessary because the
cryptocurrency has a fixed limit
of 21 million btc as it reaches its
maximum supply the rate of producing btc
decreases to provide
balance but as we've seen when a halving
happens miners experience a near 50
cut in their revenues overnight as such
it typically leads to over leveraged
miners to capitulate or stop
operating due to high costs are there
any risks as with anything
of course there are the risks of mining
are often financial
and regulatory mining in general is a
financial risk you could go through all
the effort of purchasing hundreds or
thousands of dollars worth of mining
equipment
only to have no return on your
investment that said the risk can be
mitigated if you join mining pools
another potential risk from the growth
of bitcoin mining
is the increasing energy usage required
by the computer systems running the
mining algorithms
while microchip efficiency is increased
dramatically for asic
chips the growth of the network itself
is outpacing technological progress
as a result there are concerns about the
environmental impact and carbon
footprint of bitcoin mining but there
are currently efforts to mitigate its
negative effects by seeking cleaner and
green energy sources for mining
operations
such as geothermal or solar sources not
only will you have to factor in the
costs associated with the expensive
equipment required for solving the hash
problem but you will also need to
consider the incredible amounts of
electric power mining rigs use in search
of the solution
websites like crypto compare offer a
calculator that allows you to plug in
numbers such as your hash speed and
electricity costs to estimate the costs
and benefits but if it's not for you
like we said before you can always just
buy it on the exchange or
invest in a company that manufactures
asic equipment for gpus the things that
are required to mine bitcoin
so which one are you going for mining or
investing let us know in the comments
below
if you enjoyed this video make sure you
give us a like and check out more videos
just like this
on the simply tech channel thanks for
watching and we'll see you next time